and we made it through 2021. welcome
back now that convicted sex trafficker
julian maxwell faces the rest of her
life in the big house speculation now
growing that she will flip on epstein's
pals and start quote singing like a
canary unquote in exchange for a shorter
sentence maxwell's attorneys say they
will appeal they always do and legal
experts think other people could be
going down too
well she's going to practice her singing
voice okay so i believe that all along
she has been playing her cards very very
wisely she didn't need to implicate
other people and everybody's saying hey
is trump involved is clinton involved is
leon black involved famous political
figures wealthy people but listen even
if she names names the state still has
to create a case but this would be the
time for her to start naming names i
mean after the life she's lived in
complete and lavish luxury
three hots and a cot
that doesn't look too good for her
meanwhile the heat is turning up on
other friends of epstein like royal
prince andrew and his lawyers holding
quote emergency talks unquote after
maxwell's guilty verdict so does this
canary start singing kellie i go to you
first so basically maxwell has three
options here right she can either not
talk she could talk to reduce her
sentence obviously appeal appeals
probably the not likely option in terms
of getting her out of this anytime soon
the question is do you feel the same way
i do about singing in other words you
saw good fellas and the advice to henry
hill early on was never rat on your
friends so if she rats here even if she
gets a shorter sentence what does that
do for she's 60 years old she gets out
at age 85 as opposed to 170. i i wonder
if she talks so what's your bet if you
were to bet on this right now
oh if i have to bet these are a lot of
uh slimy folks epstein and jelaine
maxwell and i believe she's singing what
incentive does she have not to sing
maybe she gets out you know has one year
left to live two years left to live if
she gets out at you know 90 95 but the
role that she had in this i mean think
about this prosecutors said you know if
you're a single middle-aged man who
invites people to go to your private
home or your ranch or your plane to new
york city you're considered creepy but
if you're a middle-aged man who has this
you know young nice-looking woman who
goes out and tries to normalize this and
talks to young girls uh it's a little
bit different maybe in the young girl's
mind there in words of prosecutors quote
lured into a trap so jalane maxwell what
a horrible thing she's done luring
people into this trap these young women
but waiting in that trap were these men
who deserve to be sought after who
deserve to have prosecutors go after
them in the same fashion they went after
maxwell this is unacceptable and if
these people didn't have millions and
millions and millions of dollars justice
would have been served here a whole lot
quicker
leslie marshall asked a very simple pity
short question given what's happened
here uh with these circumstances in the
past and people involved do you think
she's safe at this point regardless of
being behind bars
that's very interesting because there
are questions as to whether epstein
actually did kill himself very good
question joe i don't know i think
they're going to keep her very safe i
think her song should be canary in a
coal mine because i think she will be
singing snitches may end up in ditches
unless you want a deal and the bigger
the name the bigger the deal and less
the sentence time this woman is going to
get i believe you know the sad thing
here is you know we're looking for
former president's names we're looking
for princes what we forget are pilots
chauffeurs cooks maids uh butlers other
people who knew this was going on and
who were just as culpable in my and many
other people's opinion uh who kept
catching their paychecks knowing the
damage that was being done to these
young girls more than 100 that we know
of that are now women i think she
definitely will cut a deal even if it
you know cuts her sentence by a few
years i think she is keeping that black
book of hers close to the chest and
she's very smart actually she has come
from a very powerful and rich family and
that means they can hire very powerful
attorneys which she has and i i think
that may work well for her and hopefully
it'll actually work well for the victims
in the long run but i don't want to see
an immunity uh being put on the table
for this woman and that could be
something she requests as we know
cad i'll give you an option here as far
as what would you rather have access to
area 51 and all the secrets behind there
or julian maxwell's black book
go
probably this i think we should have
access to this i'm not going to predict
you know whether she's going to talk or
not because ever since we saw her at
that in and out just out there at that
in and out like everything was cool i
don't ever think i can get inside her
brain of why she does what she does when
she's in trouble but the unfortunate
thing is powerful sex predators are so
powerful because not of just themselves
because there are so many people who are
also powerful who are involved and then
there's people who are not involved but
who know about things that are going on
and could have done something but look
the other way and every time we see one
of these figureheads get taken down
there's always a bunch more people who
are either involved or knew about it who
never do get taken down so as much as i
desperately want to see everyone get
held accountable here as much as i
desperately want to know everything i
don't have that much faith in the world
let's go around the circle here as far
as the semi brady bunch thing that we
going on here right so jj i'm going to
start with you first lightning round
here okay uh pick one or two people you
think should be the most nervous right
now if maxwell does talk and go and then
we'll go to kelly leslie cat
yeah listen i think anybody who's done
anything wrong and i don't care who they
are i hope they all come out and i hope
they all go to jail this is not this is
not trivial this is talking about taking
advantage of kids you know these weren't
young women these were children and
that's a big deal and so i hope they all
burn
kelly
i think if you're on that flight
manifest uh yeah you may be in that
black book and your name may be handed
over so we'll see i don't know what
those names are
all right leslie quickly
the name i'm hearing come up again and
again who is uh saw additional legal
counsel is prince andrew so i'm going to
say that's the one we're going to be
looking at right now potentially
very good
tap it off yeah i agree with johnny joey
jones because the names i would give
would just be because of how famous
those people are and i think that anyone
who's involved in this in any capacity
is disgusting and i would like to see
them rot
i think we all agree on that certainly
coming up creepy technology is invading
our lives and causing all sorts of
problems we'll explain that one next hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else